former Vice President Joe Biden says
President Trump is being much too
lenient with Saudi Arabia in the wake of
Jamal khashoggi disappearance we spoke
with the Delaware Democrat at the
National Civil Rights Museum in Memphis
Tennessee where he was honored last
night with a Freedom Award do you have
doubts about the leadership of the Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman I do and I
have and I think there been confirmed
what doubts did you have my doubts are
that there is very little sense of rule
of law respect for human rights dignity
and you know the allegations that are
made so far no no yet are not
inconsistent with the way the Kingdom
would act so I'm very worried that the
president seems to have a love affair
with autocrats and president Trump Trump
president Trump yeah and the idea that
he's already making excuses before the
facts are known and it's typical but it
hurts us internationally if the
allegations are true and that the crown
prince of Saudi Arabia ordered the
killing of this Saudi dissident who
wrote a column for The Washington Post
should there be consequences absolutely
positively this was a permanent American
resident I just don't know why we this
administration seems to feel the need to
coddle autocrats and dictators from
Putin to Kim jong-un to you know Duarte
I mean I I don't understand it why do
you think President Trump does that I
don't want to speculate in my worst
fears but either he doesn't know what
he's doing or he has a convoluted notion
and what allows American lead the world
there are also reports that Special
Counsel Robert Muller is getting closer
to concluding and issuing findings in a
major portion of the Russia
investigation and that includes judgment
on two of the most explosive aspects of
that inquiry whether there was clear
incidents of collusion between
and Donald Trump's 2016 campaign and
whether the president took any actions
that constitute obstruction of justice
so we talked to the vice president about
that as well let me ask you about the
Muller investigation the special counsel
into influence in the 2016 election do
you believe that report should be issued
before the midterms I think you'd be
issued when they finish the
investigation
I've been around a long time you wait to
the investigation is finished you don't
put an arbitrary end to it
you wait till it's finished and let's
see what it has to say and if Democrats
win the house do you believe that they
may move forward with articles of
impeachment I hope they don't I don't
think there's a basis for doing that
right now
I think we should wait until the report
comes out